qui est un système très différent en
Chine je pense que il y a pas toujours
l'habitude de l'ouverture que un chef
démocratique peut et doit avoir avec ses
citoyens
Justin Trudeau sur l'échange qu'il avait
eu quelques heures plus tôt avec she
Jinping Canadien a été Raboué par son
homologue chinois devant une caméra
canadienne courte discussion qui a été
reprise ici un peu partout dans le monde
aussi qu'est-ce que cela veut dire pour
l'avenir des relations sinon canadiennes
voyons voir ce qu'en pense mes
collaborateurs avec Gaston gate
animateur de mes infos ici première
Chantal Hébert et chroniqueur autor
Autostar et au magazine L'actualité et
vous aurez vu que ce n'est pas Michel
dans la troisième boîte il est absent
cette semaine le chef de bureau de
Radio-Canada Ottawa Madeleine Morin se
joint à nous bonjour à vous trois
bonjour bonjour
Qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on retire
de cette de cette échange entre chez
Jinping et Justin Trudeau cette semaine
je suis certaine que Justin Trudeau n'a
pas cherché la chicane mais en même
temps le fait qu'il ne l'est pas évité
non plus je pense qu'il sort plus fort
de cette cette petite altercation si on
veut entre les deux hommes
parce que je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez dans un G20 précédent à cause
d'une de l'ordre alphabétique Justin
Trudeau de premier ministre du Canada
était assis à côté de si Jean Ping le
président de la Chine et l'ordre
alphabétique voulait que les deux hommes
étaient côte à côte et Justin Trudeau
avait essayé par tous les moyens
d'éviter son regard se tourner d'un bar
se tourner de l'autre et ça avait été
très malaisant je trouve comme incident
cette fois-ci le fait qu'il est tenu
tête au Président je pense que il
ressort plus fort du moins sur la
politique canadienne je pense que il
vient pratiquement de marquer le point
avec ça
bon évidemment si la manchette c'était
le président chinois fait un câlin juste
un Trudeau on se fait en plein de
tempête politique que on s'entend ou
même si Justin Trudeau qui participait à
un sommeil mais deux fois plus tôt
qu'une des sommets où il croit son
interlocuteur chinois
réussit à ne pas aborder la question de
l'ingérence possible de la Chine dans le
système électoral canadien la récitation
d'un employé ou d'Hydro-Québec pour des
raisons reliées à l'espionnage avec la
Chine bon il peut pas Madeleine a raison
il pouvait pas être même dans le même
candidat que le président chinois et ne
pas évoquer la question et d'ailleurs
quand on parle de fuite de soyons
sérieux ce que le bureau du premier
ministre a rendu public c'est ce que
Justin Trudeau a dit on n'a pas trahi
le secret des réponses qu'il a obtenu
et on sait pas avancer à mettre des
paroles dans la bouche du président
chinois cela dit on a tendance à
l'oublier c'est pas le premier ministre
du Canada qui se fait faire des
remontrances par la direction de
leadership chinois rappelez-vous Steven
Harper son premier voyage qui se fait
dire vous avez pris votre temps pour
vous présenter ici alors il y a le style
diplomatique de la Chine à l'égard de
pays qui ne sont pas des grandes
puissances c'est ce qu'on peut voir dans
les cours d'école quand tu es plus grand
tape sur les plus petits
pas de câlin entre chez Jean Pen et
Justin Trudeau allez que il a été
diffusé par une caméra canadienne on a
eu l'impression je sais pas si
l'impression que vous avez eu que les
Chinois ça faisait leur affaire que la
caméra s'avance aussi près il me semble
que c'est une habituelle en tout cas de
mémoire de journaliste de voir par
essence c'est un message qu'on voulait
envoyer d'après vous
je ne sais pas si c'était calculer ou
non mais je suis assez d'accord que cet
événement là très court on parle
beaucoup beaucoup de quelque chose que
pas duré très longtemps en réalité là
mais c'est beaucoup plus révélateur sur
la Chine que sur Justin Trudeau enfin
son travail grosso modo il était abordé
par le président chinois et qui était
pas content il disait écoutez nous dans
les démocraties on a un devoir de
minimum de transparence puis soyons
honnête Chantal à raison là c'est pas
comme si on avait appris grand chose sur
cette rencontre là dans les trois lignes
que le bureau du premier ministre a
rendu public et après ça ben je suis une
pénith tourne l'étalon puis il s'en va
payer pas très heureux ça a dit beaucoup
plus sur la Chine que sur le Canada
c'est à dire que la Chine se permet avec
des puissances moyennes comme le Canada
mais réputé d'avoir certaines réputation
dans le monde occidental de jouer les
durs pour passer des messages à d'autres
un peu comme l'Arabie Saoudite l'avait
fait avec les Canada à l'époque aussi on
avait on avait apostrophique pour un
tweet assez anodin puis les choses
c'était en venimeux de assez rapide
parce que l'Arabie Saoudite voulait
passer un message est-ce que les chinois
ou l'Arabie Saoudite agissent la même
manière avec l'Union européenne ou les
États-Unis la réponse est non c'est
qu'il pense qu'ils peuvent se le
permettre par rapport au Canada j'ai
intrudo lui il fait son travail il peut
pas faire grand chose de différent mais
ça a dit beaucoup sur le l'espèce
d'intimidation
douce tranquille que la Chine n'existe
imaginez si on le vu nous par rapport au
Canada mais je n'ai sur les pays voisins
de la Chine à quoi ça doit ressembler
j'attends que vous vouliez ajouter
quand même un pays qui a mis deux
Canadiens en prison sans raison
intéressé par canadien depuis 2015 sur
le front chinois
en fait effectivement je pense qu'il y a
quand même un recentrage de la part de
la politique libérale vis-à-vis de la
Chine on sait si longtemps posé des
questions je pense que les Michael ont
fait qu'il y a eu comme ça un changement
de cap et on l'a vu de façon un peu plus
claire encore avec les grandes lignes de
la stratégie Indo-Pacifique qui a été
dévoilées par Mélanie Joly la ministre
des Affaires étrangères pendant un
certain temps il y a des rumeurs qui
voulaient que dans cette politique
Indo-Pacifique le mot Chine ne serait
même pas écrit prononcé ce que
finalement Mélanie jolie en contredit en
disant la politique Indo-Pacifique
contiendra la Chine sinon c'est une
politique finalement qui vaut rien d'une
certaine façon donc on veut être plus
affirmatif vis-à-vis la Chine on l'avait
dit dans un discours ensuite il faut le
prouver sur le terrain et le fait que
Justin Trudeau se soit comme ça
est tenu à parler par exemple des
allégations d'ingérence dans les
élections en 2019 à schilding bon ben
c'est un peu la
l'exemple de ça qu'on a vu ces derniers
jours bon on va surveiller ce que ça va
vouloir dire comme Monsieur Trudeau va
revenir à tawa je vous amène sur la
scène nationale on va entendre un
certain nombre d'extraits de médecins de
médecins généralistes ministres de la
Santé sur le retour du masque ou
qu'est-ce qu'on devrait faire du masque
on écoute ça puis je reviens tout de
suite après
les gens ont pris connaissance
conscience que c'était leur
responsabilité à eux et pas seulement
une responsabilité gouvernementale
[Musique]
un peu partout au pays on a l'impression
que c'était impossible de revenir à
cette à cette règle là même si ça
devient catastrophique la situation
comment vous lisez ça vous
parce que les gens n'ont pas envie d'y
revenir c'est symbole de la pandémie
alors à remettre le masque en place de
manière obligatoire c'est un peu revenir
deux ans en arrière puis revivre des
très mauvais souvenirs alors les
gouvernements ont pas envie d'aller là
du tout
les médecins un peu partout hygiénistes
en chef directeur national de santé
publique ça serait très utile on devrait
y aller on devrait le faire
mettons que c'est pas évident moi j'ai
pris le métro puis les transports quand
même pas mal toute la semaine
normalement c'est des endroits assez
achalandés où on devrait reporter le
masque lorsque la santé publique nous le
recommande étant donné les virus la
circulation
peut-être qu'il y avait 5-6 % de plus
mais je voudrais qu'en général là c'est
moins d'une personne sur 10 qui le porte
donc les gens ont malgré le fait que les
urgences débordent malgré les virus qui
circulent pas envie de revenir au port
du masque donc politiquement ça prend ça
va prendre beaucoup beaucoup plus que ce
qu'on a actuellement comme crise pour
être capable de justifier de d'aller
dans ce sens là le gouvernement ont
vraiment pas envie de dire est-ce qu'il
y en a une option ou une voix où on se
dit OK le gouvernement va être capable
de faire accepter cette mesure-là je
peux pas imaginer et je peux pas non
plus imaginer qu'on va demander à des
enfants de continuer à faire l'école
primaire en portant des marches ou qu'on
va demander des enfants de garderie
d'emporter et ce sont des foyers ou
circulent ce genre de vieillissement
alors je pense qu'on est arrivé à la
limite de ce qu'on peut recommander par
contre rendre le vaccin contre la grippe
plus accessible gratuitement à plus de
gens au Québec par exemple ce serait
quand même un pas dans une direction
d'autres provinces sont déjà pris et sur
laquelle on travaille pas vraiment
l'autre question c'est est-ce qu'on est
en train de dire aux gens de faire
attention parce qu'on n'est pas capable
de fournir aux urgences parce que les
urgences sont pas à la hauteur au niveau
du personnel
ou si on regarde ça parce qu'il y a une
épidémie parce que c'est pas clair ça
non plus qui on protège la population ou
un système de santé que les provinces
qui réussissent pas à faire fonctionner
normalement même pas optimalement
normalement
à propos du masque est-ce que c'est
impossible de revenir en arrière moi je
pense que la pandémie nous a montré que
les promesses les règles absolues il
faut s'en tenir loin on sait pas
exactement ce que l'avenir peut nous
réserver pour ce qui est de la pandémie
mais je suis certaine que le lait
gouvernements voudrait éviter à tout
prix de revenir à une imposition du
masque parce que la santé publique en
fait oui il y a des experts de santé
publique qui vont conseiller le
gouvernement mais au bout du compte
c'est quand même les gouvernements qui
ont pris des décisions durant la
pandémie donc ça devient quand même des
décisions politiques et une décision
politique si elle n'a pas l'appui
publique sert pas à grand chose dans la
santé publique donc j'ai la question que
les gouvernements calcule en ce moment
que il n'aurait pas cette adhésion là
nécessaire pour qu'elle suivent la
population si même si le port du masque
était obligatoire ça me semble être un
excellent calcul effectivement un mot
sur la commission rouleau qui s'en vient
c'est la dernière semaine puis là c'est
vraiment des témoignages qui sont
attendus parce que c'est toute la classe
politique qui passe à partir de demain
Chantal à quoi vous vous attendez et
qu'est-ce que vous allez surveiller
a pas monsieur pollièvre s'expliquer sur
sa perception ce qu'on voit de la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence écouter moi si
j'étais un Trudeau qui va participer
j'aurais aimé mieux être le seul
pourquoi parce que le problème du
gouvernement c'est qu'il va y avoir une
série de ministre qui va défiler en plus
du Premier ministre et il faut que tout
le monde réussisse à arriver à faire pas
comme les forces de police
a donné des versions qui font un tout
plutôt que qui semble se contredire on
sait qu'il y a des maillons faibles
parmi les ministres on sait aussi que la
Commission en main les courriels les
échanges de texte en des chefs de
cabinet leur patron ministre qui peuvent
devenir assez embêtant merci donc
monsieur Trudeau a besoin d'espérer que
ça se tienne comme un tout et deux que
son gouvernement la fin de la semaine
prochaine est polaire d'un joli ramassis
d'incompétent dépassé par les événements
est-ce que ça a été Alex difficile pour
on a l'impression est-ce que les
témoignages qu'on a entendu jusqu'ici
mettre la table pour que le gouvernement
puisse justifier l'utilisation de la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence d'après
ce n'est pas par quel l'orninette on
prend on prend le débat aussi le débat
c'était est-ce que la sécurité nationale
sur le plan par exemple de la démocratie
de la survie du gouvernement était en
danger
on n'a pas entendu de témoignages alors
ce sens-là sur l'aspect économique oui
avec le port ambassadeur les entreprises
de manufactures d'auto entre autres qui
étaient obligés de fermer donc sur le
plan économique il y avait une menace
importante de sécurité nationale il y
avait le désagrément au centre-ville de
tawa qui était qui était majeur mais
est-ce que la démocratie comme par
exemple aux États-Unis lors du 6 janvier
au Capitole était en danger probablement
pas par contre le niveau de
désorganisation de la police était-elle
dans tous les corps de police autant
celui d'Ottawa que celui de la province
que celui du fédéral c'est tellement
important et on avait tellement
l'impression qu'il était rendu au bout
de leurs ressources ça va pas comment
prendre le problème quand on se dit
est-ce qu'il y avait pas de là une
décision politique nécessaire pour
fouetter il a un peu le débat pour qui
se passe quelque chose parce que moi
j'ai pas entendu rien venant des cordes
de police en disant vous savez on avait
une solution miracle qui nous ont juste
pour écouter on était capable d'y
arriver ça ce boulot on l'a pas entendu
enfin qu'est-ce que politiquement
c'était justifié étant donné la
désorganisation sur le terrain c'est ça
qui va être intéressant de voir où le le
politique a dit ben là je vais prendre
certaines responsabilités parce que trop
désorganisation sur le terrain sur ce
plan-là et peut-être là un message qui
pourrait qui pourrait être entendu on a
on a entendu d'une certaine façon où on
a compris de la part de la numéro 1 de
la GRC qu'elle aurait eu un plan pour
parler
mais
le petit et là ça a été un des éléments
marquants de la semaine dernière c'est
la conseillère en sécurité au Premier
ministre qui a dit ben quand on a un
plan on doit le dire lorsqu'on a des
informations qui sont valables lorsqu'on
a des informations qui peuvent changer
la donne on doit alerter on doit lever
la même même votre nom n'est pas sur la
liste des personnes qui sont supposées
parler au départ donc ça c'est pas
seulement une règle théorique qui a été
annoncée énoncée c'est vraiment une
critique qui a été formulée à l'endroit
de la commissaire à la GRC donc j'ai
comme l'impression qu'elle aussi va
peut-être passer un mauvais quart
d'heure là à la suite de ce témoignage
là qu'on a entendu cette semaine donc ça
a été oui le gouvernement Trudeau qui a
été d'une certaine façon en mode
défensif dans la commission parce que ou
à la suite de
du décret sur la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence parce que c'est lui qui l'a
décidé de mettre en oeuvre cette loi là
mais en même temps on a vu de la
désorganisation dans les corps de police
et eux aussi je pense qu'ils vont devoir
faire une autopsie de tout de tout ce
qui s'est passé pendant pendant ce qu'on
voit on va surveiller ça cette semaine
je vous promets qu'on va y consacrer
beaucoup beaucoup de temps la semaine
prochaine Alex Chantal Madeleine merci
d'avoir été des nôtres
ça me fait plaisir au revoir